[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to an
episode of honest trailer commentaries
for the witcher season two uh that
show's still going and so are we uh
we're gonna do some uh
who would have thought
uh coming up on ten years i think yeah
bonus trailers is amazing uh what is the
conjunction of the spheres yeah
uh we have a special guest uh danielle
didwork uh on this trailer she's under
the weather today so we got a witcher
fan in chief joe starr hey thanks for
joining us
it's very nice to see everyone hello hey
nice to see you um let's let's talk
grunts let's grunt it on uh yeah let's
just start uh talking overall thoughts
about the witcher then we'll watch the
show then we'll show some deleted scenes
which i believe there's a lot of this
time and then tease you uh with next
week's honest trailer i'm going to give
you a clue right now i can't i can
remember barely anything about the
witcher because i've just spent the last
week binging another
siri fantasy series with a ton of proper
nouns in it
give me if i get a little tongue tied
here um but what'd you guys think
overall this season joe go ahead
well i mean you can always tell when i'm
invested in a show because i start uh
without being prompted just sending you
joke pitches for yeah
for the honest trailer and which i i
think i sent you a a a lot this time so
kevin said there wouldn't be enough to
do a season two oh kevin we can squeeze
blood out of this stone any day yeah
yeah i mean i i this is one of those
things where
you know
i think the season drags a lot because
they're like time to world build
um
but at the same time it's still like i
like these actors playing these
characters so if they need to
have a ski vacation for a couple weeks
while we explain the the inner workings
of the of the continental republic
it was kind of like a ticket yeah slobs
versus snobs care moran
we've kind of got our ski school series
they're trying to shut down the winter
school
yeah i mean i i like i'd mostly agree it
felt weirdly like a filler season and
and i think what i enjoyed so much about
season one was that it didn't feel like
all the other fantasy shows like it
wasn't this like grand world build the
one quest it was like kind of a monster
of the week going on a lot of different
adventures seeing a lot of different
kinds of monsters and i really like that
and i was looking forward to more of
that and then this season really pumps
the brakes on that and is like no we're
going to stay in single locations so
we're going to really dig into this
mythology and like you know what the the
meaning of witchers and the origin of
witches and obviously they are laying
the groundwork for as joe and i were
both talking about during the making of
this like it's obviously this is a
franchise expanding
hub you know like we're gonna use this
season to do the anime shows and the
prequels and like get all these other
things spinning off and like you you
shouldn't be able to like feel that i
think so specifically and you really
feel that that like okay we're gonna
this is the vesimir thing and we're
gonna put him in and then this is like
the origin of the witcher stuff that
we're setting up for over here and like
i don't know yeah i will relate it to my
uh
entry point into this franchise which
was the witcher 3 which is one of the
best games i've ever played where it's
like if you just played the main
storyline quest this season and you
never like went off into the all the
interesting like oh i got to help this
person find their cow but uh it's a
demon like that which to me is the most
uh rewarding and interesting part of
this uh but like you said there's a lot
of groundwork covered and i hope that
they now have some freedom to just kind
of dabble around in season three and and
have uh have some more just random just
walk down a a a spooky road and see
where it takes you it doesn't all have
i think you could have kept the tone and
still done everything they needed to do
this season because the first season we
still learned about the world as we
jumped around and fought goofy [ __ ] like
we could have done in season two as well
i do just i feel like they're sort of
trying to do they're trying to capture
the
like the style of a game of thrones but
they're it doesn't feel like their heart
is into it like there there is
a a sort of gesture at politics in this
but not enough to really give you a
sense like game of thrones that of like
here's highgarden sort of take and
here's what they need and here's you
know like all of these different
families in these different areas like
game of thrones really built that
groundwork so you knew everybody's
position and what they had and what they
needed and what they couldn't afford to
sacrifice and here like i don't know
anything about radanya so
right the game of thrones
the game of thrones politics the game of
thrones politics was so rooted in like
material needs of the people and like
actual stuff happening on the ground and
when you mix the politics with high
fantasy of like we need to control the
chosen one and the destiny of the bluesy
blasey like
there's just a disconnect there yeah
they want to make expensive xeno so just
make expensive videos like that's what i
want to watch this feels like the dorn
stuff in game of thrones where we can
all feel that it's kind of half-assed
and like if your heart's not into it
just don't do it
that's not any dorn we don't need dorne
again i did overall enjoy uh this series
not as much as season one but uh i'm
still on board and we'll we'll we'll see
where we go from here let's watch the
australians i feel like uh it's like an
hour long let's go
[Music]
when it came out now after watching 18
other fantasy shows start your epic
quest of trying to remember anything
from two years ago i have absolutely no
recollection of any of these people
the witcher
season two
geralt of rivia returns and while he's
still pretty grunty
[Music]
it's funny that we
thought that he was grunting less in
season two and then when we counted it
was pretty much the same amount of
grunts
you've just started to like accept them
right yeah you overshadow them um but
yeah it was he was also talking more so
they didn't stand out as much but that
was kind of like
his verbal tick was a little
uh still going up still got it still got
a baby i mean i feel like yeah that
makes sense because like season one he
was more of like a mysterious figure to
us for the first few episodes so it
would be more just grunting yeah and
this was always grunting along with
being the the the hero of the first
season that we've gotten to know yeah
all right keep cutting
and almost as [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] are my swords
he's added a new weapon to his verbal
arsenal deep size
same dudes
um i i will say
he's really good
in this i know we we we we laugh at the
the grunt size but he's really he does
very little and gets a lot of like humor
out of it and like a lot of really funny
moments
um just with like eye rolls and weird
head tilts and stuff like that
um i realized on my second watch of this
season you really kind of have to watch
for him too like he really like hits you
right before a scene will cut you know
he'll just give like a
like a real big like gym from the office
to somebody
uh yeah it's pretty good it's pretty
funny
it is it's good because it's very
subdued like that's what the henry
cavill is really good at is like i'm
gonna stay restrained 99 of the time so
the one time i go big it has like
maximum impact it's kind of what he does
i think it fall out as well where it's
like it's so subtle for most of the time
that any big
thing seems like it has double the
impact because he's such a like a
patient performer i also think he gets
that like if this was the if geralt's
just the ultimate badass like it's
boring like i think he really gets that
where it's like because i think there
might be some actors or even writers who
would be like no man he's
he's just a grunting stabbing bathing
machine right he's not he's not riddick
he's got like he's got he's got exactly
there it is yeah yeah he's got more
inner life yeah
uh well i would say it's the role he was
born to play but clearly the role he was
born to play is some warhammer 40k
blood god or something like that um
maybe joe can help me out with some of
those um but yeah he's uh he i hope he
gets to do this as long as he wants um
because he's great wait aren't they
space marines in warhammer again yeah
but it's like it's it's it's 40k lon you
know
it's fantasy i feel like 90 of the
franchises i don't know about is just
space marines
no that's fair that's completely fair
halo they're space marines yeah they're
space birds yeah all right keep going to
a girl who is either part brooks uh
or just a normal teenage girl to be
honest
dive back into an awesome show badass
characters and all the spin-off bait
they meet along the way as our heroes
journey to a helm's deep full of
witchers with one whole personality
split between them you're choosing to be
ignorant
aren't you including vesemir the saddled
man with a spin-off backstory who's
scared of another conjunction maybe
another conjunction will come along a
junction whose function will be explored
in another spin-off and now everyone is
concerned with how they smell you both
smell truly awful even if you do smell
like [ __ ] you reek your old horse i'm
beginning to smell like an elf
guardian's ball sucks to justify the
spin-offs set in the world of deodorant
ads so what you could wash away the
stink i mean why stop there just green
light ncis blab again 90 day boar fiance
real housewives of nuff guard i mean
good i've got some fluffy biscuits
[Laughter]
there's some really well drawn nuanced
characters but that was like they took a
big stamp it's an or old-timey horns
yeah
i think she says
right after that was about a little bit
of how's your father yeah yeah
i think they took her directly from her
rent fair i think she was just the uh a
red fair worker that that wanders around
and they just they were like you exactly
you don't change anything yeah uh and
she she betrayed yen for a bit of coin
it feels like there's the
scene of like a broadway musical where
like every character comes out and sings
like one line you're like that's who
that is
she was yeah she was definitely a
prostitute you know
she was definitely about to direct you
to sweeney todd's
yeah you know that's when belle walks by
with her book and then the baker's like
my baguettes you know like
that'd be amazing if she was in the
provincial town
[Laughter]
fancy a twisted mermaid
i guess the town prostitute is still
sleeping in that scene when bell first
gets out yeah long night yeah uh well i
think that they
because like you said long that they
were there was a lot of uh scene setting
and and ground setting to maybe expand
this world and make a bigger one and i
guess i was a little let down by the
other
witchers um i've i met a few of them in
the game and i read the first book and
you know vesimir is uh
he's a he's a he's a cool character that
i imagine they explore more in that
thing but like
i don't know i guess i expected them all
to be as as cool as henry cavill as
geralt but i guess like he's just the
cool kid that got out and they're just
like the dorks that keep hanging around
the castle none of them really rose to
the level
of even close to like even supporting
him i was surprised because it's not
like this isn't really a flaw they
really don't try like there's no real
effort to other than vesamir and
geralt and then there's one who gets set
up so that it's sad when he dies uh we
don't really get to know any of the
other witchers more than like a line
here or there and it's all kind of
generic like tough guy
they're hard on you know siri or they're
making fun of each other or whatever and
it's just like yeah you would think
because it's such a big setting and it's
our first chance to meet other witchers
that they would have invested a little
more time that it's kind of weird we get
a lot we get to know a lot more mages
than we do witchers yeah and it's like
is gary like so i guess geralt's like
that with like the hair and the
bodybuilding and the grunting like just
just that's just who he is that's not a
witcher thing
i guess yeah yeah i guess i'm gonna say
this
i've watched season one a bunch now i've
watched season two twice
i've watched the prequel movie which is
cool spencer you should watch it yeah i
liked it and i still don't understand
i've never played the games i haven't
read the books
i don't know why everyone doesn't also
look like geralt and i also still don't
know what these elixirs do
i i don't know what the deal is with the
little with with the meth that they uh
that they uh take shots of to do magic i
don't know what they do
i mean i know it's like it's like
the whole thing seemed like uh
like some kind of trap house and they're
all just like cooking up these like
insane shots of hard drugs
and they're like getting really messed
up and their pupils dilate together and
then like a teenage girl comes there
it's like there's a whole uh reading of
this if it's about an opium then but
there's that one scene where they're all
about to fight for i think it might be
the last the second to last of the last
episode and they're all drinking their
little potions and i was like yeah
what's the other thing there's one other
franchise where the characters all have
to drink potions before they fight and i
was really thinking about it it is uh
disney's gummy bears from the disney
afternoon they gotta drink the gummy
berry juice right before they fight
because that's what lets them bounce
around yeah bouncing right they could
have gone in
i put it in some notes you did you did
send the picture i even sent you that
picture of you could not tell what
i just thought it was a cartoon bear i
didn't recognize the show
says the white hair is because garrett
was put through the mutation trials
twice
oh that you know what that
that's mentioned in something they've
brought that up he's like a choice baked
potato like like he's a poor guy you
like french fries
it might have been in witcher 3 the game
where they might they mentioned that
somewhere i've definitely heard that
before
i i was surprised though because they
cast tormund giant spain and that was
like a big deal and then he's just kind
of like
hey
it's me well i think they should put all
of them back in the back in the fryer
and make them a little more hardened uh
or something but yeah it just seemed
like a frat house uh okay anyways let's
keep going
gear up for a new adventure that drops
the non-linear storytelling of season
one in favor of a more straightforward
netflix series where the filler is more
obvious full of training
studying so what we'll be doing here
then studying monsters
yeah and an obstacle course that would
get yawned off of ninja warrior
because this season is less about the
monster of the week and more about
deepening relationships and character
growth sorry can't relate haven't grown
since the eighth grade now go find
something i used to doodle in my
notebook margins
oh yeah that's the stuff
yeah the politics i feel like this show
would have benefited by um given the
same budget uh and have them do
what were what were hercules episode
orders like 24 episodes 41. yeah
i really want to see the uh the basic
cable 41 episode order of this show um
and it's just people with like different
you know slight prosthetics on them and
they go oh no it exists yeah there's uh
they tried to make this already in
poland and it's a delight it's on
youtube somewhere oh wow okay so
i if you want to see which are on a on a
shoestring budget
netflix should give us one
show like that they should just do one
conventional like old style 90s
syndicated
like that was an episode to just see how
much you think that was um
the farm or what was it the ranch the
ranch i'm afraid that was the rest oh
they only did what 16 seasons they split
but they did like two seasons a year of
that show right
no they did it it was it was double any
other netflix show for sure yeah
uh it's the ranch but every uh 20
minutes they go oh astriga quick drink
your potions
[Laughter]
all right spencer did you have a
particular monster that you used to draw
in your notebooks
uh
no i i was drawing um uh people rocking
and skating
that's amazing
yeah
yeah come on hell yeah oh yeah um all
right keep going into the politics of
middle point as you track the shifting
allegiances between uh see here where my
notes
let's see strega boar friend-a-bear and
friendella of nilfgaard visimir dykstra
and philippa fridania
and a mirror of sentra
nailed it watch these bureaucrats
struggle through a plot line as boring
as the words elf migration crisis would
imply they need no other reason than the
ship of our ears and now the only hope
to bring peace between elves and men is
the widest blondest savior with magic
powers that come from having the purest
most untainted blood of all she's out of
blood there's a gene it keeps showing up
in central genealogy records eugenics
the cause of and solution to all the
continents problems
let's jump to a fan question here
because this is one that i struggle with
uh benzaiten writes uh this is a serious
request could you please delve into why
were the why there was a war who fought
who who were the good guys who are the
bad guys why are the elves hated i was
so lost only there was a wiki of some
sort
of
the only thing what's your favorite the
only thing
i
i know for certain
and is it weird that i still don't
understand a lot of this but it also
does like i'm still like this show's
great um i don't understand anything
that's happening around it but i enjoy
it um
but like
the elves are hated because they were
here first and then people as we do
showed up and were like
and yeah i guess we all kind of drove
them out i i i hesitate to to draw this
parallel because it's authority and the
political but i feel like in some ways
elves and jews are comparable in this
world that it's like there's kind of a
christian like they were there first and
they're seen as having these like dark
conspiratorial like they're not part of
us and they're working against us from
within and i think this is i'm not
saying this is andy smith i'm saying
this is intentional that it's like
that's what the metaphor is that it's
like elves are seen as this undermining
aspect in the larger society like we
can't trust them and so there's this
tension that is then exploited by
individual leaders or politicians for
their own selfish benefit
hmm but they also then like the siri of
it all like and i guess it's complicated
and i think that is what they're trying
to do is like by saying that there's
there's good people on all sides you
know um is that they like siri really is
a plot to like take over the world for
elves again
right did i understand that correctly
like they want to use her to very much
humanity again it's a little like
hellboy like yeah siri is this faded
like she's the one who's going to
reverse the trend and bring elves back
to elf supremacy but siri doesn't want
to choose that path so she's not going
to use her powers to do that even though
that was like the prophesized thing she
was supposed to do that was my
understanding continuing continuing that
line of thinking lawn because i think
that was a really brilliant comparison
what if once siri is at the height of
her powers and like grown and gone
through puberty and all that stuff they
recast her with ron perlman yes i'm 100
in favor just give her just a big stone
hand and just like
just
just mission folks yeah
all right let's keep going
catch up with a hot cast of characters
who've either with or been by fire
[Music]
okay that was real the sweet nerdy girl
who always comes in second to gary's
chaotic goth x stay with me tonight
i'm sorry yes gear the bard who scored a
number one fantasy bob then went full
emo trying to break out of his sophomore
slob
oh they wanted this to be a toss of
coins
go [ __ ] yourself yeah there we go that
one's going to my spotify wrap up daryl
it's trusty horse roach
geralt's other trusty horse roach
and jennifer who means
that is a carryover from the books or or
the lore at least is that uh there's a
lot of roaches out there much like uh
milo noticed there's a lot of
horses been replaced many times how dare
you heartbreaking
not a real they didn't really do it this
isn't um what was that hbo horse racing
series
oh
uh what was that h i don't remember but
yeah they got it
yeah they killed horses but not on
purpose um but yeah horse racing is
pretty messed up uh don't make a show
about it okay keep going
and jennifer who may have scored the
daenerys post season one my eyes are up
here contract but she's still trapped in
the same old story of boy meets girl
girl uses her magic to burn down a
forest boy believes girl has died girl
has unfortunate encounter with ancient
witch in pocket universe before losing
powers boyd discovers girl may
sacrificed war to regain magic boy and
girl put off few to combat potential
apocalypse
so enjoy
this is where um they made some big
departures from the source material and
people were up in arms uh
jennifer in the book from what i
understand is the second book i haven't
gotten to it yet she like briefly loses
her sight uh and gets it back um but in
this one they made it this whole she's
losing her powers thing and she's
willing to do anything to get it back
including sacrifice uh uh siri and it's
like they made people are really upset
that they made her
unsympathetic or too evil or you can't
you can't really follow her character
anymore that she's willing to kill
somebody to regain her magic i didn't
feel like they pushed it i can't
understand it oh you like you were
expecting the book version of the
character but i didn't think they made
her so
awful that you couldn't understand where
she was coming from or
why she was doing what she was doing
this is always weird to me because like
characters
get tempted and you know uh have
struggles and that's
part of
writing a character you know
if i can bring up just something that
doesn't really get discussed a lot you
know the last jedi
everyone like lost their [ __ ] about
luke's for two seconds he's like oh god
and then he's like no i'm good
but unfortunately that two seconds get
gets witnessed by his kid but yeah it's
like
she was like maybe maybe i'll maybe i
gotta bring a baba yaga this kid
it's a brutal world she's she's killed
before she'd kill again
too because season one was also she was
willing to do
you know some pretty reckless things
because she wanted a baby and didn't
think she'd be able to have one so i i
felt like it was a way of sort of
mirroring that and like she's still on
this journey like she wants to be a good
person and do the right thing but she's
always going to be tempted by
power and you know remembering where she
came from but it's like that's a
character like that's like yeah she
might not deal with everything the way
you would but like you understand who
she is and where she comes from and why
she might feel this way yeah a big part
of her character is still rooted in i'll
show him you know like i'll show
everybody and that'll make you do some
things and she's a person that more than
almost anyone else really knows what it
is to be without her power to be without
status to have nothing
and she's been very sincere about from
minute one like i'm never gonna go back
to
that so you do understand how she'd at
least be tempted like maybe not do it
but at least be tempted yeah agreed
interesting while we were talking about
the hellboy comparison that the the hut
in the forest that has legs and walks
around witch imagery that was also in
the david harper hellboy movie
i guess
i guess they're listed with the same
mailing european folklore
that's uh something in the cosmic
unconsciousness that makes us want a hut
to have legs
a witch in the woods in a hut that walks
around on its own power that's a uh
thing that's a baba yaga which
always confused me and john wick i was
like
he's a old lady that lives in a walking
cabin
yeah we should see if there's like a
shared producer on hellboy and witcher
because maybe it's like a uh robot
spider uh wild wild situation john
peterson
[Laughter]
someone someone check that uh okay keep
going
enjoy the smash hit show that still has
tons of rich and interesting source
material to explore and bloody epic
fight sequences to show off when it
chooses to so unless netflix gives the
show its patented three and done
treatment cowell's got plenty of witcher
money coming to keep his warhammer habit
fueled warhammer 40 000 that is my my
jam there are a lot of characters from
the warhammer versus the universe that i
want to be do you know warhammer 240
thousand that kind of stuff why is it
when i talk about lesser demons of
nurgle my girlfriend ignores me but when
he does it i have to wipe the chair down
start
what's that you have there joe what's
this
400 minutes baby yes
at your hands i've been stuck in this
house for two years
uh wait show us uh show us your never
give us a demon of nervousness what's
your favorite your favorite you have a
demon of nurgle but i do have some
warriors of corn
a parallel uh
uh god sounds very exciting are they
down with this yeah wait that's not corn
um
yeah here's this guy he's a gross fat
guy with a whip oh he's like a freaking
hole thank you
here's a um oh well spencer if i tell
you names you have to promise to sing a
metal song about them yeah
uh this is a blood secretor of corn get
up get up get down with the blunts of
greater
yeah well these are not technically 40k
these are age of sigmar which is
warhammer fantasy
um
so the regular warhammer is there in
outer space it's sci-fi but then there's
so yeah we had a fan question about this
someone asked what the 40k means
what's the 40k in warhammer 40k
i thought it was the year 40 000.
oh my god we lost joe oh
right when we needed him most
what a shame i thought it was taking
place in like 40 000 a.d that's what i
would guess 40 000. no one look it up
until like like woodstock 99. um in the
incredible year 400 000.
all right i guess we'll keep watching
the trailer he'll be back yeah
if we can if not we'll just look at just
pressing face destiny's child
so you're all very close just jenny from
the berg i can't do my magic and i need
it cured mentor the witch maker
dr ginge medicine woman
rince priebus believe science stop
stabbing yourself stop stabbing yourself
oh yeah little thumb
i don't i don't know what to do my nubs
lenscrafters lisa frank edition if this
hut's a walking don't come and knock in
what's that
[Music]
you guys might not know this but i
consider myself a bit of a loner i tend
to think of myself as a one-man white
wolf pack but when a hedgehog man
promised me siri i knew she was one of
my own and my wolf pack it grew by one
so there there were two of us in the
wolf pack i was alone at first in the
pack and siri joined in later and then
when adventuring introduced me to you
guys i thought wait a second could it be
and now i know for sure i just added two
more folks to my wolf back four of us
wolves running around the continent
together looking for monsters and baths
might be the longest
oh the elves think they've got it tough
on the continent try being a baby
[Applause]
[Music]
you made it just in time for the baby
cube yeah a lot of a lot of dead babies
we should have done well my baby back
baby
game of thrones also had a memorable
baby murdering sequence what is it with
our fantasy why is it okay in fantasy
and not well if you're if you're
continuing the uh elephant jewish
conspiracy then it's uh then it's
passover you know well that but i mean
that is one of the scenes that
definitely led me to that metaphor is
that they basically do their own uh
[ __ ] yeah um
well sweet uh you'd love to see it here
we go uh now we have uh joe's back to to
tell us about yeah what is the 40k
what's the significance of 40k that's
the year so
40k is nailed down
that was my game
so way back in the day they they made
the warhammer fantasy and then sort of
as a parody of sci-fi they made
warhammer 40k which was like grim dark
on purpose like it was clearly stupid
uh and then
everyone took it's like and now it's
kind of like the snyder cut of
miniatures or everyone takes it way too
seriously and forgot that it's sort of
supposed to be a silly like because it's
it's like world war one gaming but with
like ridiculous space marines and orcs
covered in spikes and
um space elves i've always wanted to
read these novels just because they have
the best titles of any
book
prince it's interesting that you say
that it was originally meant as like an
over-the-top grim dark parody because
that is what it feels like but then
people take it so seriously i've never
understood where it was on that spectrum
it was clearly supposed to be
silly
um uh and i think some people still get
it but then some people are just like
don't don't touch my my my uh uh
my my imperial guardsmen like they're
they're
like my soul but yeah so there's there's
the sci-fi stuff then there's fantasy
which is agent sigmar and then they also
have like a a rugby game called blood
bowl which is like
rugby with fantasy races which is kind
of fun and stupid thank you league
football that was one of my favorite
games it's uh oh my god i forgot about
mutant league football oh it's the best
fire that one back up um well yeah i've
always that warhammer 40k has always
appealed to me
and even from a distance it's like oh
this is so over the top this looks fun
like you get to pretend that you're on
like a heavy metal album cover well
we'll get up we'll get a show or
something
there's no there's no
henry cavill's on board resisting yeah
well it'll happen they all all these
platforms need more shows yeah totally
they do animation shorts right now on
their
like there's a warhammer like
plus
basically that's mostly just like hey if
you sign up you get a free model once a
year and we
but also here's like little animated
shorts um
and like there's been you know obviously
there's like total war and there's been
games and stuff like that but they've
never really made the jump
well did you show off everything you
wanted to show off because it's really
now or never joe as far as your
figurines your little dolls
i'm good but
now you know what i i think they'll all
fall over if i pick them up there's my
stormcast journals right there in that
display case
and um
yep uh
no i'm i'm good man uh
this is my life now i just sit in this
room
uh i do fandom things and then i paint
tiny men
don't we all in our own ways
uh by the way uh check joe out on uh
youtube.com backslash d d beyond
anywhere else to uh to check out joe's
current and future work is that
that's that's that's where i'm at man
just rolling them dice and roll them and
uh yep yep nice well go subscribe to
that right now and then come right back
for the deleted scenes that's what's
watching
daryl it's trusty horse roach
no
eugenics the cause of and solution to
all the continents problems oh man the
schoner's totally gonna fight me online
for that one huh
yeah plus in this point
she
there's besides to it
i feel like uh that would be too much of
a provocation so we'll see we'll see if
we get called out uh well we know she
she watched and was a fan of our witcher
season one honest trailer so she'll
probably she's gonna put eyes on this i
know
you can't think that uh people involved
are uh either enjoy your work or are
going to watch it because then you will
start tailoring it to them and i we just
have to pretend like
nobody aside from the two of us will
ever see this
yeah it is genuinely tough yeah
no i mean i fully wanted to put a joke
in about how she was trying to like make
peace with the twitter like right unite
nerd twitter uh in a grand gesture to
celebrate witcher season two in it
there's so many times where we could
talk about like
uh internet drama basically um yeah
where i just feel like that's so
ephemeral and like gone in a week that
like it's almost a niche like you know
the the percentage of the total people
who will watch this show or even this
honest trailer versus the people who
follow twitter drama it's just like a
drop in the bucket it's barely worth it
tune in next week when someone tries to
tell the world that you can restore the
snyder verse and watch peacemaker
wait you can
this is okay finally i get to watch this
i feel like you can one of the other i
was told it was one or the other um okay
keep going
in this fantasy world where power is
shared between genders and skin colors
but pointy ears that's a deal breaker
humies they need no other reason than
the shape of our ears so pause again
this is a fan question every day pretzel
ass why is it that so many fantasy shows
and sci-fi films casually dismiss horrid
concepts like eugenics and slavery and i
don't think that this kind of dismissed
yeah i don't think this dismissed them i
think it was going for a
what do you call it an allergy metaphor
clearly clearly this was about like
displaced people and refugees and they
were trying to
uh address it in a in a nuanced or like
uh
smart way but i don't know sometimes
fantasy and sci-fi and comic book films
and all this stuff i feel like isn't up
to the task because you also have to
have a lesser demon of nurgle pop out
and you need to have a chosen one with
the magic blood to unite the clans or
whatever um so look there there's times
when it's done well i don't think it was
done poorly in this um yeah but i don't
think that uh when people like oh this
is a thinking person's comic book movie
it's like you can also just
watch a regular movie where they don't
have to punch at the end
yeah i think um
on on this stuff like slavery because
this is actually a big conversation in
dungeons and dragons and stuff too
is i think slavery is like a really easy
shorthand for bad guys
and um
you know i and i think uh audiences just
get to a point where it's just kind of
like i'm i'm really tired of thinking
about slavery or hearing about it or you
know or casually dismissing it so that i
know that this like half giant is extra
bad
um
uh
and then you know as for you know the
magic blood and the chosen one and the
the pure blood stuff um
like all of our fantasy pop culture is
like so rooted in a lot of european
folklore that it's where a lot of that
stuff comes up you know all the weird
norse stuff and things like that but
it's just gonna like keep
popping up unless someone finally just
says you know what we're gonna
we're gonna not
we're gonna i mean i know that there's a
lot of there's a lot of fantasy and
sci-fi literature that doesn't have like
a chosen one at the center of it right
yeah no master race they're just not
the the biggest
ones i can think of i guess it would
just be star trek really like star wars
dune
uh witcher obviously lord of the rings
[Music]
a little bit uh yeah
it is very expressly like
aragorn needs to be the king like that's
what brings this blood and newman bruh
right yeah exactly so like they cut it
like it's almost like peter jackson kind
of like ah let's not worry that much
about that but it is very much part of
the talking thing and that's what i was
going to say like i think a lot of it is
that all of this stuff is kind of
derivative of a few really key works
that inspire this whole genre
dune and lord of the rings being very
high at the top of that list and like
yeah they're both joseph campbell s
chosen one narratives and so we kind of
inherit that and it does it takes a
it you know it's going to take some bold
new vision of how to tell these stories
to like really break us out of that mold
yeah and this is not that i think this
is a pretty good example game of thrones
you were the chosen one why
no you failed but he's just doing the
like you know the george r martin thing
is just not not do the trope but just
like flip it you know so like he's still
doing chosen one stuff he's just like
but maybe it doesn't matter i don't know
yeah lord of light who's he forget about
it yeah don't worry about it uh okay
keep going boyd discovers girl may
sacrificed war to regain magic yeah i
know the show is his own thing at all
but knowing yen would kill a kid is
going to change my next playthrough
sorry ian but
magic's gone for me
i wouldn't have tristan
oh i missed you too daddy
sorry i missed you too daddy
but at the end of the day the legendary
white wolf is only hunting for one thing
some peace and [ __ ] quiet what is it
maybe they're hiding from
stay here take siri whose voice was that
quiet shut up yes you shut up
you guys might not know this but i
consider myself a bit of a loner i tend
to think of myself
i didn't get to win
promised me siri i didn't know
so there were two of us in the wolf pack
i was alone at first in the pack and
siri joined later and then when
adventuring introduced me to you guys i
thought wait a second did it be and now
i know for sure i just added two more
folks to my wolf pack four of us wolves
running around the continent together
looking for monsters and baths well
[ __ ]
i mean if i'd seen that one i saw it
without the heads on it but if i had
seen that one that would 100
in the one we choose that's hilarious
oh man okay we can snip it and tweet it
we can snip it and tweet it give it a
little snipping tweet
um okay so uh we have some questions uh
that we didn't get to so let's get to
them now um
adam albert says i don't get the show
got so bored any time it was about about
or someone said nilfgaard how much nuff
guard could you take
i don't know if i mean you either love
nilfs or you don't baby yeah i'm on nilf
island man i just want to stay there
uh let's see
although some if if they're going full
on against uh nilfgaard i think
someone's starring named next season is
gonna have to be nilfunter
yeah
maurice who asked how many seasons does
witcher need to tell their story and i
think that it's honestly infinite but it
looks like that they're going to hue
really closely to the books so i guess
it's going to be like five um but
that's up to netflix i think that this
really could be a procedural um
and yeah well it doesn't i mean
like we're they're sort of hints that
there are big climactic things in the
offing but it doesn't really feel so
specifically like we're working towards
a specific end point like i don't know
what that would be
based on the two seasons we've seen like
what's going to happen
that is like the big fit like you know
like game of thrones was always kind of
pointing into like well eventually the
white walkers will get down here and
there will be
a war and they'll either kill us or
we'll kill them and like i don't it
doesn't feel like we have a focal point
to this story that's like well this will
happen maybe the conjunction i'm still
not 100 sure what they mean by that
yeah uh this is a good question i think
matan valencia yes uh why do you think
that netflix still hasn't gone full in
with the weekly release schedule it
could lead to a better discourse which
could save shows from cancellation or
i'll add on to this or at least like
make people interest more interested in
the witcher which i think pride maybe
pride this is how we've always done it
well yeah because it was like
it was the hot new thing like oh my god
binge drops like you could just oh
and now now that i think like amazon and
everybody else are just kind of like now
we're gonna stick to our guns here and
do weekly stuff or maybe three at a time
each week or something and
i don't know i think netflix is like no
we were right you'll come back around i
mean i believe them that they're so
metrics driven that they did some kind
of calculation was like more people
watch for more hours if you do a binge
release than if you release a week at a
time and like you lose people throughout
the series i honestly think at this
point it's as much branding as anything
else like that's what sets them apart
everybody else is doing the weekly thing
but netflix is where you go when you
want to just like
download the entire show into your brain
all at once and i think that
uh they are they are getting candy too
about what kinds of shows they make
versus not like they make these very
like disposable shows that everybody
wants to talk about for a week and then
it's over like your emily and paree kind
of things or you know like i and i or
they make stuff that you know is for
younger audiences that are going to jam
through it all in like the first few
days or whatever and so like you know i
think at that point it's as much bad as
anything else like we've obviously seen
that stuff like yellow jackets or hacks
or these shows on other
mayor of east towns a great example of
like nobody was watching it first and
then it built every week until by the
end it was this big popular thing and i
think it's just like yeah but they have
their model that they're doing and it's
all like who watches in one week and
that's all the metrics and like it's all
about these like
release something big and new every
friday and get everybody to watch it
over there yeah i just think that
literally every other service has moved
on from from the binge drop for their
big prestige things like uh paramount
apple hbo yeah all of them have amazon
was like the last hold out and then with
the boys they just were like you know
what we're spending too much money on
these forget it
uh i'm told uh brian jones writes that
netflix did a hybrid weekly release with
arcane i did not realize that yeah
they've dabbled they've done it a few
times right like a couple reality things
right where it's like we'll release a
batch this week and then a batch next
week and then a batch next year or
something like that so they have done
staggered stuff we shall see all right
uh final question uh from pat mcgonna uh
uh what book series would you like to be
turned into a film than video games than
a tv show on netflix
so it's got to do the triple crown like
the witcher wow
i mean i've probably thrown this around
before and they did do a show that i did
not see because it was like uk and it
was hard to watch in this country but
disc world okay ratchet series would
that would like specifically lend itself
to a bunch of different kinds of media i
think like i could see like here's what
the animated series would be and here's
what the movie would be and here's what
the procedural that's what they did they
did a procedural series it was like cops
in one of the big cities from the
the books and
i don't know maybe it was good i didn't
see it
oh yeah i know the city watch i believe
the watch is what it was i i'm waiting
for the library for a copy of uh guards
guards guards to check out i'm very
excited um because i've only i've only
read two early discworld ones anyways uh
also we've also talked about it before
uh i know i've brought this up because
people have asked this question before
but those that those ian banks the
culture sci-fi books
culture would be an amazing amazing
it would mostly work as films or i think
it'd be a good thing i've never read
those like civilization or something
it's really cool because it's it's like
mostly utopian it's like not just it's
like it's like the culture is this
intergalactic civilization and like
technology has made like anything
possible and they go around and like
it's almost star trek like they meet
other other cultures like the fringes of
this utopia whether they're outside of
their regions and evaluate them we're
like should we invite them to join us or
whatever like those are always the kind
of adventures and like it's all run by
these
enormous artificially intelligent
spaceships and humans are just like
fleas on their back basically yeah but
they still need us for something i don't
know it's cool it's very cool um i would
be great as films
yeah i would add in there and i think
it's being adapted at least the first
one
uh the the series is called remembrance
of earth's past but the the first book
is called the three body problem but i
know got recommended a lot there's men
there's a chinese adaptation going and
then there's also uh benny off and weiss
the game of thrones guys are working on
the u.s oh great okay
[Laughter]
no
yeah but there's also a chinese
adaptation
well it's the best thing i hate to i
don't want a broken record myself but
because video games are in the mix i was
like that would be a cool video game but
like temer man the
it's the napoleonic war but there are
also dragons
and
i just think like basically it's master
and commander but instead of a ship
they're all on a dragon oh yeah yeah
that would be a dope video game right
that would be that'd be such a dope
multiplayer video game if you're like
all on a crew on a big dragon having to
work together to go cannonball the [ __ ]
out of another one that would be super
fun
yeah napoleon is master of europe on a
dragon only the british fleet on a
dragon stands before him
battlefield i mean
like like brick backmaster commander i i
want several more of those films i think
they did one more didn't they
no not with crow and betany
i think they're going to do one more not
with chrome bentley per se but anyway
something to look into uh we got to
leave you because we we've overstayed
our welcome haven't we um but we'll be
back next week
um with another
hot topic
that's your clue
that's your clue for next week uh i hope
you enjoyed this time and joe thanks as
always for joining us uh again really
good to see everybody find them on dnd
beyond yeah this is the only time we see
each other because we're still
quarantined or at least our office isn't
open uh but um we'll we'll see what
happens later this year hope you'll be
back next week for another honest
trailer commentary thanks for watching
see ya
[Music]
you